back here on the rich eisen show is
one of the most popular members of wwe
which is as you know um on peacock which
is the exclusive streaming home of the
wwe in the united states of america
and this man's got a new book uh chosen
destiny drew mcintyre
my story drew mcintyre back here on the
rich eisen show how are you sir
i'm absolutely fantastic how are you
keeping i'm doing fine
i'm absolutely i'm keeping well i'm
keeping well congrats on the book
congrats on it thank you it's completely
surreal to hear that wwe i'm loving my
dream
i won the title a couple of times this
year and now on top of it all i've got a
freaking book about my life
so let me just take this let me let me
ask you about this freaking book
about your life uh drew um if i had told
the the kid in scotland
uh that you would write a book one day
um what would
what would that kid have said back in
the day i mean
to be completely honest i would have
said of course i will and i will achieve
all my crazy dreams of going to wwe from
scotland and winning the title because i
was a pretty cocky kid
a lot of self-belief but as the book
details i quit an interesting journey
to get to this point a lot of what's a
lot of downs and honestly it wasn't my
idea to put the book out i didn't think
to myself you know what the world needs
right now
is a wwe wrestler from scotland to write
a book that was brought to my attention
you know drew you're very open about
your story and all the interviews you do
on the television show monday night raw
would you be willing to put it down
in a book like especially the times you
were down in your life and all the
lessons you learned
i really think you could help people out
there inspire them through your story
obviously telling my wrestling story but
more my life started my personal story
the things that i've come through
and i think it was very important during
this time we've been going through the
past year that if i could help even one
person
to know there's a light at the end of
the tunnel no matter how dark times get
that's what it's all about drew mcintyre
here on the rich eisen show so let's get
into it um
the um the dark times that you're
referring to that you got through to get
to
to where you are today what what is that
not to give away too much that's in your
book but uh
go for it if you don't mind all right so
where to start
um you know i was the first ever
scotsman signed to wwe 21.
so i was living the dream in the
beginning i was right on television
one of the fastest people from you know
getting signed to wwe to be put on their
television show vince mann himself the
head of the company pointed at me on the
show
as a 23 year old and said this is the
future right here future world champion
no pressure whatsoever of course and uh
things were going as good as they could
possibly go i was literally living my
dream and then things came undone
and there was a lot of personal things
going on such as my mother
in scotland getting very sick at the
time with cancer i was a worlds away
i was such a mummy's boy growing up
close to my family i was living in
america so far away from them
she told me through skype as i had to
see her go through
all the chemotherapy treatment radiation
treatment if you come back home
i'm going to kick your butt just keep
pushing keep achieving your dream it was
really affecting me at the time
started affecting my job i started going
out more drinking more
and then she unfortunately passed and it
went from
burning the candle a little bit at both
ends to the candle being completely
engulfed in flames and
i kept this to myself if wwe knew what i
was going through
how much i was suffering they would have
got me the help i needed the mental
health
health help i needed but i kept it to
myself i suffered kind of in silence i
acted out in a lot of ways
affected me professionally personally i
got fired from my dream job
so suddenly i was fired from wwe 29
years old
no idea what to do luckily that my
current wife
and she is the one that picked me up put
me on the right path as i detail in the
book
help this crazy out of control boy who
could not deal with his emotions
finally grow up finally become a man
become successful professionally but
more importantly
grow up as a man return to wwe get to
the top of the mountain become a
two-time wwe champion
a couple of weeks i'm fighting for the
title once again a wrestlemania backlash
live on peacock going well there'll be
detail it all in the book
you know what i've never had such a
journey
as a host an answer that starts out so
introspective
and emotionally and ends so
promotionally i'll be very honestly that
was incredible
it took me you took me you took me on
her you took me on a
run right there that uh that uh i'm very
impressed i'll just say that you know
i've never
talked to me by vince mcmahon
before we get to that what did your wife
say to you that kind of got through your
skull
what did she say to you uh we kind of
had
you know a serious sit down and it
resulted after
a broken neck um i'd been outside the
company for a couple of years and i was
succeeding at the highest level outside
of wwe i was the most successful
wrestler
in the world it wasn't part of wwe i was
traveling all the time i was never home
she was holding the fort at home
i was never there i was going out all
the time and finally i broke my neck at
a show i had the first eight weeks off
that i've ever had in my entire life
like i went from university to wwe
school used to tell me what to do then
wwe told me what to do then i was a busy
hustle in the world for the first time
ever it was stationary for eight weeks
and she blindly said drew you know
things are going well right now but
you're going to crash and burn if you
keep acting like this
and the top of that i'm going to leave
your ass you're out of control this is
not healthy for you it's not healthy for
us
i spoke to her about my negative habits
i spoke to my family
i realized thankfully there wasn't an
addiction it was just a habit it was the
way i dealt with my emotions
i started opening up more to her i cut
out those negative aspects of my life i
stopped all the partying and suddenly
my head cleared i recovered from that
broken neck and as well as i was doing
suddenly i was doing
even better my body got in 100 times
better condition
my brain cloud that i assumed it was
there for the rest of my life lifted
and within two months i was talking to
triple h on the phone and i returned
back to wwe
yeah and now triple h is on the back one
of the many blurbs that's on your book
i'm looking through
seeing the photographs beautiful
photograph from your wedding right there
in florida from uh on just on 2016. this
is great man this is uh called a chosen
destiny drew mcintyre my story
wwe superstar drew mcintyre here on the
rich eisen show
all right now let's get to vince mcmahon
uh when was the
first time you met him what was that
experience like for you
terrifying you know when i mentioned
that i
we came from scotland i was straight on
wwe television i mean i was there within
three weeks
so if you can imagine myself my dreams
have been wwe i've been wrestling
professionally since i was 15 years old
but it was a part-time job because i was
in school the whole time
i got my degree at university and
criminology at 21
i was basically at uni and about within
six weeks i was part of wwe i was on the
road i was sitting and catering
just wondering what was going on over
there the undertaker i've watched my
entire life there's triple h who i've
watched my entire life
this is crazy i'm part of this roster he
killed her a b
cool drew and vincent man just sits
himself down right in front of me
he asked me how i was doing and in my
head i'm like oh my god that's vincent
man
don't dance stupid so we have a kind a
casual conversation that lasts
probably about a minute tells me good
luck walks off
and all i think to myself is this is 13
years ago
oh my god my accent was so thick back
then i mumbled still to this day
he didn't understand a word
that's basically what i thought that
first conversation i ruined it all
your accent's too sick he didn't
understand a word you said
but it's all worked out what was it like
uh to be uh in the home of the super
bowl this year
just a few months ago on wrestlemania
we're watching some of your uh action
what was that like for you
that was unbelievable um it was a point
of the show
and i'm sure if you're following it with
the weather that we thought for a second
it might not go ahead and
if you've you know followed my career
read the book you know my first ever
world title match was last year
wrestlemania we had the worldwide
pandemic
we put the show on in front of nobody
gave everyone escape during those
difficult times i won the wwe title and
brought lesnar fast forward a year later
we've got the fans back and once again
fighting for the title we're going to
redo an american hometown
nothing can go wrong and then suddenly
the rain's coming down like crazy
we're evacuating fans in and out the
building we do the national anthem at
the beginning
with the whole roster on the stage i get
to the back first i'm ready for the
first match and with the first guy that
walks out from the fans for the first
time
in one year one month in one day and i
could tell drew
there's gonna be a 40-minute delay what
do you mean it's gonna be a four-minute
delay
for the weather so there's a lot of
emotions going through me number one
being
am i jinxed the past two years i've been
fighting for the title
and suddenly with that worldwide
pandemic we've got this weather delay
whatever we got through it i was the
first person to walk out in front of
that crowd and they had been saving up
that reaction for an entire year like it
was unbelievable to see them live in
person
to hear them just screaming cheering
crazy as i come out there i literally
almost started crying i'm not
in fact i'm proud to admit i don't care
i miss the fans like i almost had tears
coming down my face this wasn't live
back in that building
but people across the world watching the
show in that moment i'm hoping they felt
like
that's it we're getting so close to them
back to normal again look at that crowd
at wrestlemania hey look you know i mean
athletes want to entertain you know what
i mean and so
when it comes down to it you want you
want a crowd you want to
you know you want to feed off it um you
know so
um yeah of course you want the fans
there i don't blame you for getting
emotional
you know i i get emotional and i'm just
calling the event you know what i mean
like so it's just i i i hear you drew
good on you yeah that's such a big part
of our show in wwe as well like
they're our number one superstar they
create that unique atmosphere you get in
wwe they're so loud so passionate
so interactive they can dictate the flow
of a show and change the flow of the
show
by their reactions and not having them
there you know has been very difficult
to have them back there's just a
reminder of how important they are to us
as wwe superstars you got a question for
him tj jefferson rich eisen show
uh wrestling aficionado you had a good
one for him last time he was on i'll
give you the floor one more time what do
you got for hey drew what's up brother
hi brother so um one quick thing
drew about your book that you and i have
in common a little bit
yesterday i appeared on the price is
right okay
we shot this episode back in march
tonight the price is right yes
so i was on the prices right we watched
it live on air just to get everyone's
reaction now
i know from your book that you film
wrestlemania last year a month in
advance and then you couldn't say
anything for
a few weeks until the show actually
aired so i understood where you were at
i couldn't say anything about
price is right and you couldn't say
anything about wrestlemania so
you know i was i was filling you on that
one um
but one thing i do want to ask you drew
i'd like to ask all the wrestlers is
if you had to assemble an all-time
survivor series team
five members yourself included of
wrestlers in their prime who would you
pick
oh my goodness every time i put on the
spot with these things i
answer them then later on i go i should
have said
this person oh let's just throw a few
names in
the obvious ones let's see about andre
the giant
the undertaker maybe
brittany hart in his prime
local steve austin is prime is pretty
much unbeatable
oh there we go and the mana face last
year brock lesnar that seems like a bit
of a
team right there later on i'm going to
start thinking to myself damn it i
should have put this person in
the left let's just go with that right
now okay remember by the way if that was
four i'm obviously the last member
no it's it was five i think it was five
and
um you you can you can be five plus one
and if you
want to amend it uh we'll have you back
on soon uh
but don't jump one of the guys and take
their spot i'm definitely part of that
team if i have to jump
of course and take a spot that's fine
okay i i like that no doubt
and uh you know and and when you had to
wait uh a month to tell somebody about
for your wrestlemania pre-record to be
revealed
similar to what tj went through for the
price is right is it also similar to
tj's experience that
after wrestlemania all you did was walk
away with a ping-pong table and a
popcorn machine
it was actually a week in advance sorry
not a month and i put the wwe
championship when i won it and we
pre-recorded it in like
i'm in the office right now i put it in
the closet and i told myself nothing's
official in entertainment or wwe till
it's official
things change a whole bunch of my career
so i don't believe anything until it
happens even if it's pre-recorded
i put it in the office if you listen to
my media during that week when i'm
talking about the match
you would have 100 believe that we
didn't pre-record it because in my mind
of course
nothing's official to us of course we
watched it on the sofa my wife and i
with our cats
and when they i won the title and the
refuse presenting me with the
championship on tv the coolest thing
about it was my wife has been such a big
part of my journey presented me the
title in real life
which is a really special moment that is
great what are your cats names drew
what do you got my cat's names are chas
and hunter
not named after triple h she's a part
main [ __ ] known for their hunting and
intelligence
[Laughter]
well uh tj he got a championship he did
um and all you got was just a ping pong
table and a popcorn machine but
other than that it's all going up a ping
pong table or a popcorn machine if that
helps
does that help it makes me feel i mean
it makes me feel a little bit better
about the situation drew
thanks hey drew congrats on the book uh
i always enjoy our chats that's now two
for two i've always
uh enjoyed your work as well thanks for
coming on here let's do it again soon
please
absolutely thank you for having me once
again appreciate the time and i look
forward to doing it again in the future
at d mcintyre wwe on twitter and
instagram and again where all books are
sold at chosen destiny
drew mcintyre my story one to root four
right there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here